>>> NEW IN MORNING A RUSSIAN
COURT HAS UPHELD U.S. BASKETBALL
STAR BRITTNEY GRINER'S
CONVICTION FOR SMUGGLING DRUGS
IN THE COUNTRY.
HER NINE-YEAR PRISON SENTENCE
MAY BE SLIGHTLY DECREASED FOR
TIME SPENT IN CUSTODY.
IT'S UNCLEAR, THOUGH, JUST HOW
MUCH IT COULD BE REDUCED.
BEFORE THE JUDGE'S RULING GRINER
APOLOGIZED FOR WHAT SHE CALLED
HER MISTAKE.
>> I'VE BEEN HERE ALMOST EIGHT
MONTHS AND PEOPLE WITH MORE
SEVERE CRIMES HAVE GOTTEN LESS
THAN WHAT I WAS GIVEN.
I WANT TO ALSO APOLOGIZE FOR
THIS MISTAKE.
AS I SAID IN MY FIRST COURT
THAT, YES, I PLEAD GUILTY.
I DID NOT INTEND TO DO THIS, BUT
I UNDERSTAND THE CHARGES BROUGHT
AGAINST ME AND I JUST HOPE THAT
THAT IS ALSO TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT.
>> JOINING ME NOW STATE
DEPARTMENT SPOKESPERSON NED
PRICE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING.
JAKE SULLIVAN SAYING IN A
STATEMENT THAT YOU'VE CONTINUED
TO ENGAGE WITH RUSSIA THROUGH
EVERY AVAILABLE CHANNEL.
YOU SAID AS RECENTLY AS
YESTERDAY THE DISCUSSIONS ARE
ONGOING, SUBSTANTIAL PROPOSALS
HAVE BEEN PUT FORWARD, BUT BASED
ON WHAT WE SAW THIS MORNING,
WHAT'S NEXT HERE?
>> WELL, WHAT WE SAW THIS
MORNING WAS A REMINDER THAT THIS
PROCESS HAS BEEN A SHAM FROM THE
START.
TODAY HAS BEEN ANOTHER SAD DAY
FOR JUSTICE IN RUSSIA.
I USE THAT TERM JUSTICE VERY
LOOSELY, OF COURSE, BECAUSE
JUSTICE HAS ALLUDED THIS CASE
FROM THE START.
THE RULE OF LAW HAS ALLUDED THIS
CASE FROM THE START,
INCREASINGLY THE RULE OF LAW IS
ABSENT IN RUSSIA WRIT LARGE.
THAT'S WHY WE MADE THE
DETERMINATION A NUMBER OF MONTHS
AGO THAT BRITTNEY GRINER IS
WRONGFULLY HELD, JUST AS IS PAUL
WHELAN, ANOTHER AMERICAN CITIZEN
WHO HAS BEEN HELD IN RUSSIA FOR
FAR TOO LONG.
AS YOU ALLUDED TO, WE DID PUT
FORWARD WHAT WE CALLED A
SUBSTANTIAL PROPOSAL, A NUMBER
OF MONTHS AGO, TO RUSSIAN
AUTHORITIES, SECRETARY BLINKEN
MADE PUBLIC THE NEWS OF THAT
SUBSTANTIAL PROPOSAL RIGHT HERE
IN THIS BRIEFING ROOM A FEW
MONTHS AGO NOW.
WE CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH THE
RUSSIANS, THOSE CONVERSATIONS
HAVE TAKEN PLACE EVEN IN RECENT
DAYS.
THIS HAS NOT BEEN A STATIC
PROCESS.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO URGE THEM
TO ENGAGE AND TO ENGAGE
SERIOUSLY ON THIS BECAUSE WE
WANT TO SEE PAUL, WITH HE WANT
TO SEE BRITTNEY RETURNED TO
THEIR LOVING FAMILIES AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
>> TWO POINTS, YOU WANT TO SEE
THEM ENGAGE SERIOUSLY.
ARE THEY NOT ENGAGING SERIOUSLY?
>> WELL, THE FACT THAT PAUL
WHELAN AND BRITTNEY GRINER STILL
SIT BEHIND BARS IN RUSSIA
SUGGESTS TO US THAT THIS PROCESS
HAS NOT MOVED AS QUICKLY AS WE
WOULD LIKE, AS QUICKLY AS IT
WOULD NEED TO.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE SATISFIED
UNTIL PAUL AND BRITTNEY ARE HOME
WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
UP UNTIL NOW THE RUSSIANS
HAVEN'T ENGAGED IN A WAY THAT WE
WOULD CONSIDER SERIOUS.
WE WANT THEM TO CHANGE THAT
POSTURE, WE WANT THEM TO ENGAGE
CONSTRUCTIVELY, WE WANT THEM TO
ENGAGE ON THE PROPOSAL THAT WE
PUT FORWARD.
>> I'M GOING TO ASK YOU RAPID
FIRE BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A NUMBER
OF TOPICS WE WANT TO GET TO.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOLD JAKE TAPPER
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO THAT HE
WOULD MEET WITH PUTIN AT THE G20
SUMMIT NEXT MONTH IF PUTIN SAID
HE WANTED TO TALK ABOUT GRINER'S
RELEASE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY INDICATION FROM
THE KREMLIN THAT THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY?
>> THE PRESIDENT ALSO SAID THAT
HE HAS NO INTENTION OF MEETING
WITH PRESIDENT PUTIN AT THE G20.
WE'VE ALSO MADE CLEAR THAT WHEN
OUR INTERESTS ARE IMPLICATED AND
OF COURSE THE WRONGFUL DETENTION
OF WHELAN AND GRINER IS OF GREAT
INTEREST OF US WE'RE WILLING TO
ENGAGE.
TO REITERATE THAT SUBSTANTIAL
PROPOSAL AND TO SO I WANT THAT
ON IBRAHIM AMADDY, HE TRAVELED
THERE A YEAR AGO TO VISIT FAMILY
AND WAS HELD ON 14 TWEETS SENT
OVER A LONG SPAN OF YEARS.
HIS SON AS YOU KNOW VERY
FRUSTRATED WITH HOW THIS IS
BEING HANDLED.
HE TOLD CNN HE THINKS IT WOULD
BE HANDLED DIFFERENTLY IF HIS
NAME WAS IN THE HEADLINES EVERY
MORNING HAD HE BEEN HELD IN
RUSSIA OR IRAN.
AND THE FAMILY WANTS THE U.S. TO
SAY -- THE STATE DEPARTMENT TO
SAY THAT HE TOO IS BEING
WRONGFULLY HELD.
WHERE DOES THAT STAND?
>> WELL I CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO
IMAGINE, WE CAN'T BEGIN TO
IMAGINE THE AGONY THAT AHMADY IS
GOING THROUGH.
THAT HIS ENTIRE FAMILY IS GOING
THROUGH.
WE HAVE MADE CONSISTENTLY CLEAR
TO SAUDI AUTHORITIES THAT THE
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION SHOULD
NEVER BE CRIMINALIZED.
THE EXERCISE OF A UNIVERSAL
RIGHT LIKE FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION
SHOULD NEVER BEEN CRIMINALIZED.
WE HAVE ENGAGED WITH SAUDI
AUTHORITIES FROM THIS BUILDING
HERE IN WASHINGTON.
WE'VE DONE SO FROM OUR EMBASSY
IN SAUDI ARABIA.
WE'RE CONTINUING TO SUPPORT ASAD
AND HIS FAMILY AND CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE EVERY FORM OF ASSISTANCE
THAT WE CAN.
>> IS HE BEING WRONGFULLY
DETAINED.
>> THIS IS A PROCESS BASED ON
CRITERIA THAT ARE SPELLED OUT IN
BOTH LAW AND POLICY.
WE ALWAYS LOOK AT THE TOTALITY
WHEN IT COMES TO A PARTICULAR
CASE SO THE BOOK IS NEVER
CLOSED.
WE'RE ENGAGING WITH THE FAMILY
AND SAUDI AUTHORITIES AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE SUPPORT HIM
AND HIS FAMILY IN EVERY WAY WE
CAN.
>> WE'LL CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR
THAT AND SEE WHAT DETERMINATION
YOU COME TO.
BEFORE I LET YOU GO, I DO WANT
TO GET YOUR TAKE ON UKRAINE.
30 CONGRESS ASKING TO END THE
WAR IF UKRAINE.
I KNOW YOU'VE SAID FOR DIPLOMACY
TO WORK BOTH PARTIES NEED TO BE
ENGAGED HERE.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT EROSION
WHEN IT COMES TO SUPPORT FOR
UKRAINE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE MOVING FORWARD?
>> ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
PILLARS OF OUR APPROACH TO
UKRAINE HAS BEEN THE FACT THAT
WE'VE ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
FROM CONGRESS OVER THE COURSE OF
THE BETTER PART OF A YEAR NOW.
IT IS BEEN BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THAT ALLOWED US TO PROVIDE?
$17 BILLION IN SECURITY
ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE SINCE THE
START OF RUSSIA'S INVASION.
MORE THAN $8 BILLION IN ECONOMIC
ASSISTANCE.
WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT WILL CONTINUE.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE DIPLOMACY,
NO ONE WANTS TO SEE AN END TO
THIS WAR MORE THAN OUR UKRAINIAN
PARTNERS AND OUR UKRAINIAN
PARTNERS INCLUDING UP TO AND
INCLUDING PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
HAVE MADE CLEAR THIS WAR COULD
ONLY END THROUGH DIPLOMACY AND
DIALOGUE.
THE UKRAINIANS HAVE MADE THAT
CLEAR.
BUT IT TAKES TWO ENGAGE IN
DIALOGUE.
THE RUSSIANS ARE NOT READY
ENGAGE IN THE SORT OF DIALOGUE
AND DIPLOMACY THAT WILL BE
NEEDED TO END THIS WAR.
THAT IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
DIPLOMACY BETWEEN UKRAINE AND
RUSSIA.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE ARE THERE TO
SUPPORT UKRAINE.
WE'RE GOING TO EMPOWER THEM ON
THE BATTLEFIELD THAT WILL
EMPOWER THEM AT THE NEGOTIATING
TABLE WHEN T